Major breaking news as the Supreme
Court's decision in Charles versus
Salazar has just advanced the ball when
it comes to the fight for AR-15s.
That's right. You're not going to
believe what the Supreme Court says. We
will be able to use this big time, maybe
as early as a couple months from now
when we fight for the AR-15
semi-automatic rifle ban cases in front
of the US Supreme Court. That's right,
folks. Let's break it down when we come
back. some great news out of this
decision that will be useful fighting
for our rights in the context of the
Second Amendment. Let's break it down.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four boxes of proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court, and I'm
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you 2025 and
2026 gun news awards. All right, folks.
As you know, the US Supreme Court has
issued a huge ruling out of Colorado in
the case of Charles versus Salazar. Now,
in this case, this is the case involving
the talk therapist who had a license
from the state of Colorado that wanted
to talk to her clients and patients
about whether or not they were really
experiencing gender dysphoria. And to
the extent there was any question about
what to do, the rule in Colorado before
the Supreme Court decision was that you
could only encourage the transition from
a boy to a girl or a girl to a boy. You
could not ask the person essentially,
well, maybe we should not transition
you. Maybe you really are a boy in a
boy's body and you're just going through
a tough patch here. Anyway, the Supreme
Court says that the Colorado law
basically violated the First Amendment
and therefore the Colorado law was no
can do. That's essentially what the
court said.
But here is the critical thing because
it's my job to find information,
evidence, precedence that we in the
Second Amendment community can use to
advance our right to bear arms. And that
is exactly what's just occurred in the
Supreme Court decision of Charles versus
Salazar. Specifically, the Supreme Court
took the task, the defendant in this
case, the state of Colorado, and said,
"Oh, you're trying to redefine talking
as conduct. You're trying to redefine
talking with clients as sort of
professional conduct. Well, no can do
because no matter what a state says in
terms of the definition they use, we the
Supreme Court do not have to embrace it.
Why is this a big deal for the right to
keep and bear arms? The answer is every
single anti-gun jurisdiction in America
that bans AR-15s or magazines to hold
more than 10 rounds. What do they do?
They label ordinary semi-automatic
rifles what? Assault weapons. Assault
rifles. That's how they define them. So
too, when it comes to an ordinary
magazine, a standard capacity magazine,
BFD, really, right? Well, of course, the
anti-gun jurisdictions call them large
capacity magazines.
Well, I'm happy to report there's a 0%
chance that the Supreme Court is going
to be adopting those insane definitions
in light of this ruling in Charles
versus Salazar because they basically
just said that no matter what a state
labels something, that doesn't make it
true. That doesn't make it so. And the
Supreme Court is not bound by those
definitions. So, let's start with
specifically what the Supreme Court had
to say. Then I'm going to tie it into an
article in the Harvard Journal of Law
and Public Policy a few years ago by a
very handsome YouTuber with wonderful
hair that I think you all know and love.
But let's start first of all with
Justice Gorsches and the Supreme Court's
critical language about definitions and
whether or not the Supreme Court will
actually just accept just on its own, if
you will, the definitions of political
propaganda terms by these deep blue
states such as, oh, I don't know,
Colorado. Check it out. Justice Gorsuch
wrote at the 10th Circuit Court of
Appeals, Judge Harts dissented. He
points out that while Colorado's law may
ban conduct in other applications, the
judge observed with respect to Miss
Childles, it regulates only what she may
and may not say.
To the contrary, Justice Gorsuch wrote,
talking about Judge Hart's, "The
majority's effort to recast Miss Child's
speech as professional conduct amounted
to little more than a labeling game."
Uhoh. The Supreme Court is on to this
game being played by these deep blue
states to label ordinary conduct bad
ordinary guns, assault rifles, ordinary
magazines, large capacity magazines. In
this case, Colorado said, "Oh, no. We're
not regulating speech and therefore the
first amendment's right to free speech
is not implicated, your honors. We're
dealing with professional conduct by a
licensed therapist." And what did the
Supreme Court just say? Ha, very funny.
Colorado, no can do. You're making up
stuff and we're not going to be bound by
your insane definitions, your insane
labeling game. No can do because Miss
Charles is talking to our clients and
you're restricting what she can and
cannot say. That is viewpoint
discrimination. And in this case, it
violates the First Amendment right to
free speech. That means the Supreme
Court is well aware of the attempts by
these overreaching state governments to
redefine stuff in some way to get it out
from under having to go through
constitutional scrutiny. Here's the next
thing that Justice Gorsuch had to say.
Slapping really Colorado around saying,
"Hey, this argument about relabeling is
a game and we are not going to tolerate
it. We're going to label it as it what
it really is." which in this case a
child versus Salazar, a restriction on
free speech by a woman who talks for a
living and articulates her viewpoints to
patients for a living that you're
interfering with. That is not allowed.
Here's what Justice Gors had to say
again describing this labeling game as
something that the Supreme Court will
not tolerate or endorse. Check it out.
The state of Colorado's premise is
simply mistaken. In many applications,
the state's law banning conversion
therapy may address conduct such as
aversive physical interventions. But
here, Miss Child seeks to engage only in
speech. And as applied to her, the law
regulates what she may say. Her speech
does not become conduct. Listen
carefully. Her speech does not become
conduct just because the state of
Colorado may call it that. Uh-oh. bad
for the anti-guners.
Justice Gorsuch goes on to say, "Nor
does her speech become conduct just
because it can also be described as a
quote unquote treatment, a therapeutic
modality or anything else for that
matter. The First Amendment is no word
game, and the rights it protects cannot
be renamed away or their protections
nullified by mere labels."
That's very very very bad news for the
anti-gunners when they go before the
Supreme Court. I'm hoping in the next,
you know, several months in an AR-15
semi-automatic rifle ban. I think that's
very bad news for the anti-gunners
because the whole premise of their bans
on semi-automatic rifles, AR-15s,
uh, magazines that hold more than 10
rounds. The whole premise is they get to
wave a magic wand and claim these things
are assault weapons or large capacity
magazines. and they somehow think that
labeling these as such makes it true.
But this Supreme Court is like, "Yeah,
we're not that dumb. We're not naive. We
can see exactly through. We can see
through exactly what you're doing here,
Colorado." And I can assure you that
when the anti-g gunners come before the
Supreme Court labeling AR-15s and
semi-automatic rifles assault weapons,
the Supreme Court's going to scoff at
that. Now, I'm not saying that the three
liberals might not be okay with it, but
the reality is uh it ain't not it will
not fly with this court. And this proves
the point. And by the way, I'm happy to
report that I have pointed out before um
in the Harvard Journal of Law and Public
Policy and articles exactly how this
phrase assault weapon or assault rifles
are literally just madeup terms. So,
here's something I wrote about a few
years ago. See if it rings kind of true,
kind of similar to what the US Supreme
Court just said. I'll let you put
together the dots here, but here's what
I wrote in the Harvard Journal of Law
and Public Policy. Let me know what you
think about it and see if it connects
the dots up with oh, I don't know, the
United States Supreme Court itself.
Check it out. Quote unquote, assault
weapon bans, unconstitutional laws for a
madeup category of firearms by Mark W.
Smith. I'm especially excited to talk
about whether commonly owned
semi-automatic rifles, which happen to
have a handful of incidental features
built in or attached to them, are
protected by the Second Amendment.
Spoiler alert, the answer is yes.
Ordinary semi-automatic rifles, just
like ordinary semi-automatic handguns,
are protected by the Second Amendment's
right to keep and bear arms. The United
States Supreme Court's legal precedents
confirm the same. These constitutional
protections do not disappear. Listen
carefully, folks. These constitutional
protections do not disappear
merely because the anti-gun lobby
chooses to label or perhaps more
accurately mislabel
these ordinary firearms as assault
weapons. Indeed, as Justice Thomas
astutely recognized, the term assault
weapon is a political term developed by
anti-gun publicists. Not bad. Not bad,
right? You like that? Well, let's see
what else I have to say next about
definitions and quote unquote assault
rifles or assault weapons. Because of
the semi-automatic rifle's appearance,
coupled with certain features that are
arbitrarily included in some assault
weapon that's quote unquote assault
weapon ban statutes, an ordinary rifle
gets converted definitionally, hear what
I just said, gets converted
definitionally into an assault weapon.
Well, I guess I'm on a roll. At least I
was in this article. But then I sum it
up as follows. And then again, let me
know if you think that the language I
read from the US Supreme Court in the
Charles versus Salerser case rings kind
of true or speaks or at least rhymes
with some of the things that I'm quoting
from my article in the Harvard Journal
Law and Public Policy. Here's kind of my
last observation about what I said about
the term assault weapon being a madeup
political propaganda term that has no
real meaning outside of just being
labeled as such by dark blue
jurisdictions that hate guns. Check out
what Mark Smith said here. I want to
talk for a few minutes about what
exactly is an assault weapon. If you
take away only one thing from today,
please remember this. When you see the
words quote unquote assault weapon, this
is not a factual denotative definition
or term. This is a political propaganda
label used by people who want to ban or
severely restrict civilian ownership of
firearms. Well, there you have it.
Again, if you think the US Supreme Court
in light of what they just wrote in
Charles Ree Salazar that we don't care
what Colorado labeled speech versus
conduct versus professional misconduct,
whatever it is, we're going to look at
what's really going on here. That is
exactly what the US Supreme Court's
going to do when they hear hopefully
very soon an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle
ban case and maybe even the magazines.
They're going to look exactly what this
stuff is. They're going to look right
through the political propaganda
language and the labels and the fake
definitions advanced by the anti-gun
propagandists and the anti-gun
politicians and whatnot. And they're
going to see through all this and
they're going to describe exactly what
these weapons are, which are ordinary,
commonly owned and used semi-automatic
rifles. no different than the
semi-automatic handguns that were found
to be protected by the Second Amendment
in that case in 2008 of the District of
Columbia versus Heler. All right, folks.
Anyway, I think this is very good news.
This is how you connect up the dots
between other Supreme Court decisions,
other Supreme Court precedents, and you
bring it to bear to win for your side.
And this is how we use the First
Amendment case of Charles versus Salazar
just decided to advance the right to
keep and bear arms. Anyway, there you
have it. Hope you enjoyed today's
episode. Make sure you follow me over
there on X4box Diner. Don't forget to
subscribe both the Rumble and the
YouTube. And I look forward to talking
to all of you real soon here at the Four
Boxes Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.